ja aber ich bin mir wieder da und ich
bin wieder zurück meine sehr verehrten
zuschauer ich verliere euch eigentlich
gar nicht auf jeden fall ich euch mal
wieder auch trainer gesagt ich freunde
schicken doch mal irgendwelche videos
ein wo irgendwas macht deswegen würde
ich sagen dass wir direkt absteigen tut
nur deren luca und der holz richtenden
grund packen und pisten dazu ja locker
das kannst nur du da muss ich glaube ich
nichts mehr zu sagen gibt
an der stelle muss ich wirklich mal ganz
kurz anmerken dass ich kein einziges
wort von dem verstehen was du gerade
versucht mir mitzuteilen
karmann-werk ruhig sagen also bei blur
kleiner junge ich weiß jetzt nicht was
du mir genau mitteilen wollte es mit
deinem video erwarten dabei das ist
genau richtig meine damen und herren
wenn ihr etwas bestellt
dann ist wirklich die beste option dass
man einfach das mädchen heißen nehmen
gibt es einfach in die hand und pop bis
in den müller war ich zeige euch mal wie
wir nehmen das einfach so da und ist ein
mülleimer und jetzt packt ihn das
einfach sogar ein
das ist so das ist super
oh mein gott freude das huhn meldet sich
zurück mit einem neuen video also ich
würde sagen wir schauen mal was dort
jetzt thema ist heute berichtet möchtest
du mich heiraten das habe ich ja letztes
mal in dem video gesagt wo das hormon
ein liebeslied für mich geschrieben
hatte habe ich dann angefangen haben
willst du mich heiraten und mal schauen
was jetzt passiert meine damen und
herren
[Musik]
ein biss beauty wellness pokemon greift
an
[Musik]
also luca hat jetzt als attacke pizza
eingesetzt und die pizza sehr effektiv
gegen baby mal schauen die babys antwort
darauf sein wird
[Musik]
also bibi hat angegriffen mit schlechter
musik also mit ihrem lied überhaupt bafa
allerdings hat luca den schaden
absolviert und jetzt schauen wir mal was
baby diesmal einsetzt
[Musik]
babys beauty palace hat die bina toren
eingesetzt also kommentare die auf die
seite sind allerdings mit luca jetzt
denke ich komplett ausrasten
[Musik]
platz luca moro 100 gegen baby für die
pellets den pokémon kampf gewonnen
es gibt nichts besseres was sie mir grad
hätte vorstellen können
also ja ich muss schon sagen es war
lustig diesem jungen zu sehen der in
seiner hand offenburger gepackt hat und
deswegen wie explodiert ist aber freunde
dass es hart gefährlich macht das bitte
nie wieder jemand der früher in unsere
schule gegangen ist hatte china böller
in der hand explodiert bekommen lassen
haben tun keine ahnung was und da ist
eine hand so halb abgegangen also spielt
bitte nicht mit so was rum es tut mir
leid dass ich jetzt wieder spaß
spielverderber bin oder so aber das ist
ja echt hart gefährlich man denkt hier
erstmal okay das ist jetzt ein ganz
normaler reese werbespot irgendwie aber
freunde habt ihr das hier gesehen
in dem spot war meine pizza die lag auf
dem schreibtisch von dem typen von rewe
freude wie krank ist das bitte wie
bereits gesagt arbeiten wir derzeit
schon auf hochtouren an einer zweiten
pizza also was heißt auf hochtouren wir
überlegen uns gerade wie wir die event
machen könnten
[Musik]
das ist auch meine standard reaktion
wenn mich einer fragt ob es geschmeckt
habe mich wohl direkt mein handy raus
und trage luca - shop.de
[Musik]
egal was ist mit dir also klares
virtualized bei mir an uns vorbei hey
bist du komplett bescheuert bisher ich
frag mich in diesem format immer okay
ich habe jetzt gerade ein video andere
personen die sich jetzt gerade irgendwie
meine merchandise über einen boden rollt
kann es noch schlimmer werden es teil
der personen die kinder einfach sein
trinkwasser auf den boden
ich meine ja vollkommen in ordnung hier
o mein gott freundes kleines zurückkehrt
schon länger nichts mehr diesem format
von sich gegeben
mal schauen was der diesmal für eine
aussage verrat afrika
kuchen denn ich hasse apfelkuchen an der
stelle würde ich das video ist
allerdings auch beenden weil der damen
und herren das tut mir leid dass das
video heute so spät kam irgendwie erst
gegen halb neun oder so allerdings war
ich heute auf den tag übernahmen
verdammen weil wir da spontan
hingefahren waren also tütchen verleiht
wenn ich das wieder allerdings gefallen
hat wie ich mich sehr sehr wohl aber
einen daumen hoch von euch freuen ihr
mann daumen hoch
[Musik]